probably 90 percent of contracts are
going to be compromised so we 90 of
smart contracts are going to be
compromised today there is about three
billion dollars at risk in high risk
contracts we're sitting doing one of our
research sessions with uh with a
prospective user and he was looking at
the screen as super early prototype he
was like looking perplexed he's like
that's an F why is it an F because it
has what we call our flexivity which is
that spiral X similar to USD and Luna
and it started kind of getting word and
he's like in my head that was an a I
have seven figures in that liquidity
pool and he literally he was running
away from the office to go exit that
position and we had an aha moment we're
like [ __ ] this is what it's about all
right guys bang bang uh I thought a
great place to start would just be the
difference between C5 or centralized
Financial Services uh and D5
decentralized Financial Services there's
a ton of people talking about this right
now uh mainly because a lot of
centralized Services have blown up and
it appears that many of the
decentralized services have not how do
you all think through the differences uh
and similarities of C5 and D5 well C5
was written Finance as it has been built
uh for the past 100 years
it is based on the fact that people
trust each other and D5 is actually the
opposite it's about not caring who you
are and so in decentralized finance
everything is decentralized meaning that
you don't have to trust a counterpart
and so it there is no counterparty risk
and so that's the big big difference and
big change with D5 is that like we're
taking out the key risk that created all
the crisis in finance over the past 70
years uh because you don't have to trust
anyone you can have full transparency
you see what is in the code and you can
trust the code because the blockchain is
going to uh uh like do what the code
says code is low when you look at the
code like are people actually going and
reading hey this is exactly what it says
and uh I've identified some
vulnerability are people smart enough to
do that you know I don't think I could
go and look at like a uh some sort of D5
product and underline uh and underwrite
the actual code itself so am I relying
on someone else or their audits like how
does that work yeah so transparency
doesn't fix everything for sure
um there is a very high level of
expertise and technicality first you
need to be able to read the code you
need to be able to interpret the code
and see like what kind of design kind of
protocol design it creates what are the
incentives and is this sustainable over
time so for example for us we are going
to rely exponential we are going to rely
on Auditors on looking at the
technicalities of the smart contract to
see if there is a back door or this like
if this is uh like uh something we can
trust and then we are going to look into
everything related to protocol design
the economics of the protocol to be able
to assess the risk of a smart contract
how do you guys think about the
percentage of problems in D5 like back
doors uh bad code is it like one percent
of the time is it eighty percent of the
time it how do you just yeah try to
identify like how bad is it or how good
is it currently yeah we go with the idea
that like probably 90 of contracts uh
are going to be compromised so we 90 of
smart contracts are going to be
compromised yeah it's a little bit like
you remember uh before 2017 uh all the
icos probably 99 of those coins didn't
make any sense and uh we think that more
or less the same thing is going to
happen in terms of like smart contracts
where you know risk is hard so
anything can take you down and with our
framework at exponential for example we
are looking at thousands of risk vectors
things that can take you down and any of
these ones like for example backdoor on
a smart contract can uh drain the funds
so
we're we're like at the Crux of the
issues like C5 comes with a ton of risk
and we've seen it recently especially
counterparty and credit risk because
you're trusting someone
defy gives you trustless which is
amazing because it's free it's open you
know what's going on now it's so open
that now you need a framework to figure
out what's good versus what's that and
so and that's what we're building at
exponential RFI it's uh the ability to
understand our our framework can be
simplified into a grade A to F so this
is an a this is an f and here is y and
to answer your question with with like
some numbers there were about 60 billion
uh dollars lost to vulnerabilities over
the past four years today there is about
three billion dollars at risk in
high-risk contracts that we've
identified actually that are would be
rated basically D or F in our framework
yeah so a to F is like the the grading
here and what makes something an A
versus a B versus a c like I think the
extremes good versus bad yeah or like
people can wrap their heads around but
when you get into more the granular
differences between grading what is the
difference yeah so
um our framework is Bill built on facts
that's that's that's uh that's the first
thing it's stable Stakes it's like we
the most basic thing is has the protocol
been audited who are the Auditors are
they uh are they reputable uh and then
we look at the vertical code quality at
the protocol maturity of course if it's
younger it's it's it's more risky so we
effectively
um our grade is not opaque so it's not
like oh it's an A and that's it it's
like it's an A and here is like all the
metrics we've looked at and and so on
and so forth and how we've come to to
that conclusion uh and so you're able to
to for someone who wants to understand
high level the type of risk I'm getting
X percent yield but it's a d versus I'm
getting Z percent yield but it's an A
and and make those types of trade-offs
you can do it but when you want to
understand okay it's an F why because
well its design is exactly like a UST uh
Luna type of what we call that spiral
risk and there is a lot of that today
going on which encompasses a lot of the
three billion at risk that I'm that I
mentioned and many you want to elaborate
a bit on the framework as well yeah I
mean we look at risk from like a very
Financial Theory perspective like really
like the best way to look at risk and
things that we don't like mess with is
for example there is a compost ability
in D5 like contracts feed on each other
and so
um before exponential.fi you would see
like uh scorecards with like just like
uh ticking boxes and saying okay you
fair 95 but those five percent can can
take the whole contract down and so what
we do is like we look into almost like
actuaries uh like we look at
probabilities of these facts or criteria
like the fact that there is not enough
decentralization for example uh from the
team or the team has still like a
multi-sig of three to five uh uh being
able to drain the funds for example we
took take that and we assign a
probability of risk and then we we do
something that is actually super
important with everything related to
risk is that we compound the risk so if
you have a risk uh typically on a smart
on a pool for example that makes a urine
pool eat we eat teeth
well you have the risk of the wrapped if
you have the risk of state has risk
related to Lido Lido has its own
protocol design and risk so we are going
to look at uh the urine the curve the
Lido risks and we are going to compound
all of them and so that gives you a
better sense of the probability of
having a problem with that smart
contract or that pool and so we really
went back to like the fundamentals of
Finance the fundamentals of risk Theory
and we assign all these risk-like
actuaries so that it helps you define
whether you are in a safe place in a
battle tested smart contract like a or
we are trying something new and there
are risks that we have identified that
are obvious that we have seen somewhere
else like with tracks for example that
has a certain level of uh like a dead
spiral risk really a little bit like the
USD of of Terror Luna and so those those
are the cases where we try to to give
you like a quick sense of where the
problem is how are people using the
grades right so uh I go somewhere and I
see oh this is a c what do I do with
that information it's one thing to to
have the information but like what do I
changing my behavior what am I doing
differently so a grade cannot tell you
when something will fail or if it will
fail
it's relative all it tells you is that
it's more risky than a b
and a b is more so everything is
relative and so uh and an A has good
design fundamentally good code audited
Etc but it's not it's not going to be
able to predict everything but what it
really isn't necessarily risk-free and
that isn't guaranteed to fail that's
right but it is a relative comparison in
terms of the risk based on the
information that you guys have that's
right exactly but what it allows you to
do which is very useful is is find the
right investment opportunity for you so
with defy it's super open It's amazing
And it removes some of the issues we've
seen with C5 right uh recently in
particular uh and uh both you need the
right framework to make the right
decision for you so I'm getting 10 TL
then it's an A or I'm getting 40 TL then
it's an F I can make that decision
because I'm able to understand some
sometimes like you may be getting low
yield like a three percent deal but it's
actually a D
um this all came about it's a funny
story actually
um uh when when we built decided to
build this before building the ability
to actually invest which is ultimately
what we want to do we are we're sitting
doing one of our research sessions with
uh with a prospective user actually a
next colleague of mine and
and he was looking at the screen as
super early prototype and he looks at he
was like looking perplexed and it's like
that's an F
and I'm like yeah he was like why is it
an F like because it has what we call
our flexivity which is that spiral
similar to to USD and Luna and he
started kind of getting word and he's
like in my head that was an a I have
seven figures in that liquidity pool and
he literally he was running away from
the office to go exit that position and
we had an aha moment we're like [ __ ]
this is what it's about we need to tell
people what like what type of risk
what's going on with defy and so on and
so forth so what's interesting to me
here is uh in light of
um all of the I'll call it like long
tail crypto stuff that's blown up right
we've seen uh whether it's a
decentralized I'll put that in air
quotes platforms ended up not being
decentralized there's these debt spirals
all that stuff to then even centralize
platforms one of the big questions is
like would disclosures have changed uh
the way that people react right or
interact with these platforms
um and so you can see a world where uh
in the traditional Financial them
there's disclosures people make
disclosures and then people still decide
to buy things that maybe in hindsight
they shouldn't have bought or things
that they thought were valued at X and
ended up being at x minus you know 80 or
whatever yeah so how do you all think
about like disclosures and what benefit
that could bring to an industry like
this versus what I'll call like the
grading system which is uh a reputable
firm that's actually going in and doing
the grading is the
are those the same thing at the end of
the day or do they give two different
data points for people to use in the
ecosystem
I think both are needed so if you need a
grading system to know very quickly as a
user or an investor what do you want to
do is this interesting to you and so
that's a quick way to help you in the
decision making process once you have
decided that this is of Interest a pool
or investment opportunity you are
looking into understanding it more and
so in the due diligence process you need
that ability to look into transparent
information and so what we do is like we
are going to look into we use our risk
framework it's holistic it's trying to
capture as many risks as possible
anything that we can imagine and then we
go into these facts one by one and say
all right what's the level of uh
decentralization is there some
reflexivity in this contract is there
like a dependency that we didn't think
of and we bring all of that information
which is like pretty heavy and
complicated and complex but we do as
much as possible a job to simplify that
in in a way that is easy to understand
for anyone who would be like a
knowledgeable investor and be able to
look into these risks one by one and
read through it that's what we have on
the pool page we have the whole risk
framework for every pool
now that there is
disclosures
that
no one can understand aren't helpful
if it's all legal speak that like it may
not be that that's that's there for for
like uh form uh what we care about is
providing information and disclosures
that users can act on and understand at
a deep level so the grade is here to as
a warning oh it's an F it's red or it's
a d and then you go into it and you can
read facts you know in an easy to
understand interface with words like the
sparkle has been audited or this
protocol has not been audited this
protocol is less than a year old
therefore it increases risks I'm going
to the most based one it can be like
there there's some more complex ones
obviously uh there but that's what we're
about about a framework that makes
disclosures uh understandable and
decision making better because that's
what's needed we believe in D5 it's an
amazing ecosystem but it needs some like
table Stakes things uh to help people uh
like make the most of it effectively
yeah what is the biggest risk
that is as like pervasive as you guys uh
can see that most people don't
understand so yes it's less than a year
old okay people understand that and they
basically can just look hey when was it
started right yeah uh but what is the
thing that you're like is most like the
most mispriced in uh in the industry
right I think it's the date's parallel
risk it's the reflective explain this in
more detail what is a debt spiral risk
so for example in the case of uh the
Terra Luna UST
when ustdpacks
you have to sell more Luna which
decreases the price of Luna and
decreases the chance for the change to
sustain itself so you end up with a
circle where all of a sudden
UST is less trustworthy you also have a
dead spiral risk sometimes when you end
up having a company in C5 that has more
liabilities than assets like it happened
with FTX for example you start to have a
dead spiral because you don't have that
yet before before the run the bank run
so what happens is that you have more
people getting out which increases the
risk that you will be left naked at the
end and so you have to get out and so
these debts parallel risks are risks
that are not apparent that you can't see
them before you do an in-depth analysis
to look into how things connect to each
other so what we built for example that
is
very unique with exponential IFI is we
built what what we call the the defy
graph the D5 graph is basically mapping
all the smart contracts one to each
other like we we basically have to look
into all right yearn is using curve
curve is using Lido and so on and like
or we have a wbtc which is based on uh
bitco doing the custody and backing it
one to one so when there is a problem
somewhere let's say wbtc you can see all
the pro all the pools that will be
affected and so that's also important
when you look at this system
how do can you just look at how it's
structured or do you have to go actually
look at the code like if you were to
read a white paper for example could you
identify oh this has debt spiral risk or
do you have to actually read the code to
understand so the death spiral risk is
not in the code the death spiral risk is
all almost like metaco it's like what
connects to each other and it it
requires like looking into the typical
Financial uh risks uh that risk
departments in finance and Wall Street I
used to which is like saying all right
if I lend to three Arrow capital and
three hour capital is doing High
leverage well
log file block file lending to three
Arrow capital is actually taking some of
the risk of three Arrow capital's
leverage and so
that means that we just need to look
into the connections the dependencies
and what happens behind that dependency
that code that connection and so it
means that we almost have to to be aware
of the risks everywhere that they exist
not just the risk of the pool or the
smart contract the first one we have to
look into the
second third order effect
I would I would just add to put it in in
simple words
don't pack things with vaporware or or
basically a token you've created backing
things with uh reliable tokens is is key
so that there would be a red flag or an
important race uh the level of
collateralization is also important so
if something is under collateralized we
would flag it in the framework and then
third one is hacks obviously if if the
protocol has been hacked multiple times
it's a reflection on their on their code
quality and therefore a high risk so
those those would be other important
risks you look at yeah
how important or how advantageous is it
that when you're looking at the
dependencies the chain reactions that
you can actually identify Wallets on
chain and understand okay this is your
wallet here's what's in that wallet
that's something that nutritional
Finance you can't look in people's bank
accounts and so does this like added
layer of I think some people would argue
transparency others would argue
auditability does that help you get a
better handle on what the risk is or
could it actually be confusing and like
having too much information actually
makes it more difficult
um it's actually helpful helpful to us
and the user more importantly because
that the way we've built our framework
or our first feature is called rate my
wallet you can enter your wallet it
tells you what's abcdf in your wallet
effectively very useful because it
allows you to so for the user that
transparency all about transfer enables
them to instantly figure out uh what
what they got into
um and maybe maybe want to yeah yeah I
would say like it's it's very useful for
everyone to know what's the position of
everyone basically uh that helps a lot
with what we do in terms of like uh
building the default graph would not be
possible with Wall Street because of the
opacity of the system and that creates
all these like Cycles where we leverage
too much then like there is like a
downturn uh when we're bullish we go
leverage and like all of that cycle
doesn't need to to exist with D5
um yeah rate my wallet basically looks
at the assets that are in someone's
wallet and tells them you know high risk
low risk here's your grade exactly
what's I I think that out of everything
you guys have said so far the part that
uh will surprise people the most is that
90 of smart contracts you all think will
be compromised at some point in this D5
world uh is that a death sentence for
defy like 90 could be compromised does
that mean like hey the system doesn't
work or is it no we understand that
people should be aware of the risks but
like this will still persist how do you
think about it no so we are at the very
beginning of D5 and what we see is that
we are building the infrastructure of
the internet of money
so what it means that like once we have
for example a smart contract like uni
swap that create does a job that is real
which is like you are able to swap one
asset by another and that's like a job
that exists in in normal Finance Market
making uh that we have now a smart
contract do for you that job is needed
and being able to do it in a
decentralized fashion is phenomenal into
it's mind-blowing so it is like a real
job behind this
what what you need is like you need a
little bit of time to test the contract
you need to have V2 today has been used
with billions of assets and billions of
dollars of swaps
um it has been around for more than two
years it kind of start to be battle
tested
that infrastructure that becomes
infrastructure of the internet that
becomes real what we should call
protocols we should not call protocols
everything we should call protocols
things that are like in the internet you
have TCP SMTP HTTP all of these are
actually real protocol that you can rely
on and that build a internet that is
decentralized that is like censorship
resistant and that is coming as well to
D5
probably the case with uni swap V2 a
code uh a little bit probably less the
case on like Urban compound that's
definitely better on IBM compound than
many other lending protocols and so what
you have is like you have like all these
new jobs that are becoming decentralized
that don't require humans human
intervention anymore that are being done
jobs that are being done by blockchains
by basically machines and that's
something that's actually revolutionary
all you need is to be able to bring
liquidity real assets behind it and that
helps you create a yield so all of this
like is an ecosystem that is very
innocent it is normal in that process
that 90 of smart contracts would have an
issue but what we see is that this is a
anti-fragile system aware ecosystem that
is basically learning as as it fails and
once we have looked into reflex activity
once we have looked into a smart
contract that was not a hundred percent
plus collateralized with like strong
assets we know that these are problems
and exponential FIS mission for us we we
come with the idea that we have to
make the learning stick like we have to
crystallize that
bringing it to the risk framework and so
staying aware of all these problems so
that like anyone can see them one
important Nuance to um because 90 is is
a large number
and or and and it is about the level at
which it's it's compromised within that
you're gonna have what does that mean
that means you can have small things and
you have you're going to have major
things like USC and Luna so that's what
it means that means that number there
are a lot of issues that occur there are
small bugs that will get fixed that
still are considered issues and should
be captured and and so on and so forth
so that that's in a nascent ecosystem or
in fact in any like new product
development that's typically how it
works where you you you you learn over
time and make progress and you have like
different types of issues some are minor
some are major what we're trying to do
with the framework is outline the
likelihood of hitting these tips these
types of issue if you invest in a c for
example it's like kind of middle middle
right there that means that it will give
you a better yield most likely uh but it
comes with some risks meaning the
likelihood of having some of these
issues or vulnerabilities will happen so
that could be a minor hack for example
that doesn't have a a major Financial
issue but that the protocol will
resolve learn from and then move to a
new version that will be stronger over
time and so on and so forth if it's a
deal or not F in then the likelihood
like what we flagged is things that can
make you lose all your money which are
which are a lot bigger but effectively
eventually the system will converge into
stability and we'll see more A's and B's
in our framework but it will take a
little bit of time yeah and one
important distinction there
um 90 is about smart contracts by
numbers we're not talking about locked
value or lost value right now for
example we're looking into three billion
that could be that are at a high risk
and contracts so you think three billion
dollars of assets of a market that is I
don't know half a half a trillion or so
could be at risk given some of these uh
potentially uh compromisable smart
contracts yeah less than that we
basically did not learn our lesson and
and that's something that we that's
where you see an F or a d and we tell
you like you should probably get out
today do you guys ever say that like
would you ever tell people like hey you
should get out of this or does that
cross the line into like now you're
giving Financial advice and so you you
can only arm people with as much
information and like Risk disclosures or
transparency as possible the latter so
our our entire framework is about
providing the information for the user
to make their own decision it's
educational it's there for clarity and
transparency but we we can't tell
someone get out or get in that's not
that's not for us to say if someone
wants to take risks that's their
decision but what we can do is provide
them as much information as possible so
they can make the the best possible
decision for them so the most important
part is to know what's the why yeah why
yeah and then so so uh one of the things
I've always been interested in um is
like these smart systems or these
automated systems so forget for a second
is it using a blockchain technology is
it using some other technology or what
like almost the the engineers and smart
people will figure that out but like
from a theoretical standpoint the
ability for machines to transfer value
between machines obviously if you use
two-day settlement times of dollars in
the traditional Financial system that's
not going to work right and so whether
it's stable coins Bitcoin something else
whatever this like automatic transfer of
value in a uh uh a very simple low-cost
instantaneous manner between machines
okay that that makes it uh sense the
second thing then is like taking
regulations or laws and coding them
actually into these systems so if I'm an
accredited investor or you're not I have
a reg d uh security I can't transfer it
to you within some time frame that would
break the rules so the system doesn't
allow me to do that
is there a world where you all see the
risk ratings that you all are creating
can almost be interjected integrated
coded into these automated systems and
people could set parameters and say like
hey uh I'm going to go operate in this
world but I don't want to touch or be
dependent on anything that has a d or F
rating and so in some way you almost uh
back into like enforceable rules not
just around the risk rating but it's the
end user who's deciding what that
parameter ends up being yeah absolutely
that's that's something uh that that
we'd be very excited about but that's
the user's decision again all we can do
is provide them with a tool they can
decide what they can invest in but yes
in the future we could build a feature
that says uh invest uh in an eat BTC
pool that's only rated A and B for
example based on your framework and then
obviously they would need to understand
what a and b means which is on our site
because it's again it's not a black box
you can like understand specifically why
it's going on and we think this is quite
powerful because
it allows people to invest
to get the yield that they want with the
level of the risk that matches their
their risk profile and and that's that's
quite powerful we when we first started
this thing we're like okay let's just
simplify investing that's how that's how
that was our first goal right and then
as we start working on it it's like well
you can't do that we can't do that if if
if if if someone is going to invest in
in a in an F what we call an app or
something super risky on our platform
it's it's just not uh something that we
stand for so before building the ability
to invest we're like all right uh there
is no great risk framework for D5 it's
an amazing ecosystem let's build that
and let's help the ecosystem so we're
having this very productive discussions
with protocols where we're together
we're like okay like let's make things
better like how based on the framework
like okay this is this is rated C why uh
uh what's the how can we do better type
of jail and then we get feedback back
while your framework has a flaw there
like whoa fix it at this metric great
sounds great and so so this whole
discussion around risk is needed to like
make the ecosystem uh grow in the long
term and so we started there and then
eventually yeah we want
um the the investing in defies is super
hard today like you got to deal with
self-custody you'll deal with bridging
uh you got to deal with uh figuring out
which smart contract to invest in uh
tons of research so it's hard right and
it's reserved for a small amount of
people that have the time to do that
what we want to do is like one click you
go just like on on on on on on in
traditional finance and you can invest
in any pool across any chain in D5
that's that's what we're building right
but before allowing that we want the
ability for users to say okay I'm
investing in a c i want to take a little
bit more risk cool here why is it a c or
is why cool I understand it Go and uh
that's We Believe also it's aligned
um with what Regulators would want
because we're disclosing uh what's going
on in in the instrument before uh before
an investor essentially uh and like puts
money in it how does regulation play
into all of this there's a lot of people
specific critics I think that have kind
of seen the last you know year play out
or so and they're like oh that's because
there's no regulation now people will
debate whether there's regulation is it
good enough whatever but like how do you
all see that evolving over time and does
that help or hurt uh kind of a value
proposition of what you all are building
yeah so uh we think that
um
ultimately
our goals are aligned with uh uh with
The Regulators goals that's how we're
designing the platform so our our
philosophy is help the user make great
decision provide them with the right
information uh don't mess with users
fund everything is backed one to one so
we have a lot of like key principles
that would be aligned uh with that so
there there needs to be a level of
framework created by Regulators I think
it'll happen over time and I think we'll
adapt to it as it comes but what we're
trying to do is get ahead of it uh and
uh and build things the right way so
that
um
so that it benefits the ecosystem in in
the long run and ideally regulations
will uh will eventually follow and uh
and have have essentially uh supports
the the ecosystem uh uh by putting the
right uh guard rails but without
constraining it either that would be the
dream essentially and I think you'll
move in that direction eventually yeah
when we think about this industry in
general even though things have blown up
there's this perceived risk that you all
are highlighting is it still growing or
has it plateaued in terms of growth like
how do you all think about uh where we
are today and where maybe it's going
from like a growth standpoint I mean in
terms of numbers uh you you have like uh
care metrics that show that it plateaued
uh for and it's probably going to
Plateau for the bull cycle the the bear
Market uh that's that's how we look at
it but it's not necessarily in terms of
like decreased amount oh it's you have
less leverage in the system that's good
and that that means like there is less
job of lending and borrowing the other
job that you have is automated Market
making which is like the job of trading
you can like coinbase uh exchanges uh
they show that like uh the volumes
decreased and so this similarly you
would see that in terms of automated
Market making so with these two jobs
lending and borrowing and Market making
you probably like have
um like headwinds however we also see
like a lot of new protocols we'll also
see a lot of more uh composability in D5
and there are like there are a lot and
also like
um there is more and more people
getting into the the this ecosystem
every day and so
um
I think it's just a question of time
fundamentally Defy is here uh like has
really good reasons to to be there
we we need a more uh transparent system
we need a more decentralized system and
so we are making a bet on the future but
I think everybody every hodler is making
a bet on the future of crypto
look it's winter so
let's not sure go ahead uh and
um
uh and D5 has has taken the hit as well
but if you look at what's happening is
unsustainable plays are going away
sustainable plays are surviving where
are the sustainable plays in defy
and and and particularly the protocols
are designed right that would be rated
aob for example and and so that is very
promising for the ecosystem because it
means that the way it's built the
trustless manner everything
collateralized for good protocols and so
on and so forth is uh Will Survive a
major crisis like uh as bad as as it
gets and so
um it is uh currently winter but as the
ecosystem uh or overall heals uh money
will flow back into D5 the right way and
that that's that that's our that's our
goal here
um and um yeah how does Bitcoin fit into
all of this right
um
many people myself included would argue
Bitcoin is decentralized Bitcoin has uh
the lightning Network there's all kinds
of uh experimentation Innovation
happening on side chains and and various
other types of uh things that people are
trying to build is it
defy and Bitcoin are separate are they
related to each other in some way do
they coexist in the future is it a
zero-sum game like how do you all think
about these two things which I think get
talked about in silos usually but like
is there a relationship or a competition
like how do you think about it I'll make
a quick comment and then um so
um metaphorically speaking
if Bitcoin is your apartment
if I gives you your rent so they're very
complementary actually it the beauty of
D5 is it allows you to access yield that
was previously reserved for banks and so
you can take your assets including
Bitcoin and put them to work on D5 by
lending them or doing Market making and
generating yield so the two are are very
complementary they feed off each other
effectively and Medi um you know you
yeah
I think that there are like two big
stories it's almost like having two
revolutions at the same time and trying
to mix both of them with the same words
they're both Finance but it's very
different Finance Bitcoin is about
revolutionizing the Central Bank like
changing money separating the States
from money and that's like a very big
undertaking it's phenomenal it's going
to bring
a lot to humanity and uh I'm very
bullish on that
um D5 is something different it's about
intimidation it's about disrupting
intermediation
replacing uh humans by blockchains about
code
and providing a system that is more open
more transparent and without
counterparty risk as much as possible
and so that in itself is a different
Revolution a it's very important for
Humanity and is going to bring a lot for
everyone the reason it's also so
good a revolution you see like you have
robotics you have ai and let's say you
have blockchain
and Robotics is probably going to be a
few companies creating the best robots
same thing is going to happen with AI
it's like going to be like a few coders
who have all all the benefits of that in
D5 it's all flipped and anyone can
actually participate in that so it is
actually also something that's very
important in terms of uh Pro there is
the opportunity to give access to
everyone to defy and so that's why it
became such an important mission for us
to make to Level Playing Field to make
it easy for people to get access to the
information understand risk or have a
good way to to to to assess it and be
able to have access to to defy
talk a little bit about your backgrounds
right I invested in the company and I
think that uh I invested at the best
time which was like you guys had a
couple of ideas of things to go work on
but I was like oh here's two smart guys
who um are gonna go and try to figure it
out right and you've tried some things
you've tried other things and you kind
of continue uh to get to a point that
you are now which I think is like very
clear hey we underwrite the risk uh and
we're able to transparently explain that
to people I think a lot of people are
shocked frankly by some of the things
you all have uncovered but what are your
personal backgrounds and and why are you
so interested in coming and building
these types of companies in in this
space yeah so there are three we're
three co-founders uh and uh so Medi
comes uh from uh traditional Finance
background but uh this whole thing
started as it was helping his friends
and family invest in crypto and then
move to defy and he was like sitting on
my couch and looking
perplexed and and I'm like what you up
to is like I'm trying to invest in D5
for for one of my like uh LPS quote
unquote which was a family or a friend
there and and he was doing a bridge and
uh super nervous because he was a large
amount and I'm like okay show me what
it's all about that sounds a lot more
interesting that's what's going on and
and and and that that kind of that's the
Genesis of exponential right there I was
like oh my God we got to productize that
that's incredible your Market making on
my couch I was like okay your Market's
making on my couch that's super cool
let's do it and then so that was the
beginning so midi brings in the the
finance and crypto expertise
um uh Greg our other co-founder uh and
CTO is uh X Amazon uh led the the
acquisition for a company into Amazon uh
deep fintech background
um and so on and so forth and myself uh
product uh and looked after everything
fintech at uh at Uber for a while so we
have kind of very complimentary
backgrounds between technical product
management crypto and defy in in the
team at the founding level
and then when we started hiring we're
like who should we hire right so uh and
so uh one uh one one one of our
investors says you should sprinkle in
some degens that was the the term and I
was like no uh we are a bridge between
web 2 and web 3 effectively that's what
we're building and so we're we're about
our entire team is in Shirley hybrid we
bring the best of web 2 people who comes
from fintech who understand like that
side of the world and we bring people
who are like super djans into web3 as
well as part of the core team and you
see it every day there is like some
heated debates now we should do it this
way no we should do it that way to have
a deal and and that's what and
essentially enables you to build a
bridge or an access Gateway because we
have those type of debates and that type
of like mixed skill set in in the team
that creates very interesting
conversations yeah why are people
leaving their jobs now like it makes a
lot of sense in the bull market yeah
right people like oh I'm gonna go and
I'm gonna make money or it's exciting or
I'm reading in the news all the time my
family's talking about it like this is
like the thing I should go do in a bear
Market it's almost the exact opposite
like everyone's like this is dying it's
going away whatever why do you see
people quitting jobs and traditional
Finance or Tech or wherever and joining
now I think it comes down to whether you
see the light it's
um
Defy is definitely the future there is
like a lot that is there in terms of
like transparency in terms of like
building the Lego blocks of Finance
from start and building it the right way
everything should be asset
collateralized at a more than 100
percent everything should be uh if there
is risk you could you should be able to
see it and so
um
basically like it comes down to people
who believe in it and that's something
actually like one of the criteria that
we have uh is is definitely going to be
uh able to understand what D5 means and
what's it is about to become
it's like each types of candidates if
they come from traditional uh fintech or
or just uh web in general
um
the do you introduce them to crypto and
D5 actually so typically there are
different levels effectively what we do
is uh uh first thing we do before after
our first call is we send them like uh
there is like a PDF that has everything
about D5 as well as links to code bases
to go look at and play around with uh to
understand uh D5 better and use is
simple you get one of two reactions
about a week or two later it's either
okay it's not for me or oh my God or
have I been this entire time what's up
like so so and so and and you get like
about like maybe 20 of the people in
that second category but those those are
the people you want who will like
realize the power of decentralization
the power of like how the ecosystem is
built to provide opportunities to to to
everyone uh how
um
yield uh and people don't underestimate
the power of compounding like if you
give yield to uh an average investor uh
with compounding they will build their
wealth over time and then now they can
access real yield in D5 that's that's
very powerful if they do it the right
way and uh and and when people dig into
uh that and get excited about it then
we're like okay they're they're ready
for a conversion obviously if they're
already into Define crypto that that's a
different type of hire as well yeah is
there a specific product protocol smart
contract that is very popular like has
gotten an F yes like what like what is
like the most uh uh mispriced uh one in
terms of like tons of people use it but
you guys are like holy [ __ ] this is a
huge problem so issue the warning it's
it's a
um
it's it's moving like so for us frax was
a problem it was basically the same
architecture uh as Luna with
higher qualitization ratios but for us
anything that is
related to assets that are a little bit
porous is a problem
and so USD was porous uh what does that
mean porous meaning that behind the UST
you don't have a dollar
you actually have five cents of a dollar
so
if you have a 95 cents on a dollar
then you create a risk of reflexivity of
that spiral why because when there is a
bank run the first ones are selling
their USD for dollars and so that 95
ratio becomes 90 and it goes down and
down and down so the last ones have zero
and so that's the kind of risk that we
don't like so frax is actually doing a
lot in terms of like building more of
these barriers to sustain the one dollar
pack
and so we have to look into it every
three months because they do adapt to
the market and change things so we have
a review of frax that's coming uh this
month another thing that we don't feel
comfortable with and we think that it's
actually like the opposite of D5 is and
collateralized lending if you have n
collateralized Lending
then the only way to sustain that is
probably going to have a level of
centralization and when we look at
centralization we don't like it like
because the uncoateralized lending
basically the only way to do it is to
have decentralization and that's where
you all see a lot of risk yeah so if you
have in collateralized lending you have
credit risk or counterparty risk
counterparty risk is the opposite of
what D5 is built for D5 is built so that
every Lego block is something that you
can trust
because it's fully backed if you have
uncollateralized lending it means that
you have to trust the the the borrower
to pay you back but they have actually
bad incentives to pay you back so what
these and collateralized lending
protocols do is that they build all
these incentives for the uncoateralized
lender borrower to pay you back but then
what is going to happen when you have to
move from metaverse to meet space
what does as as as like the liquidity
provider you are going through a smart
contract let's say this is a
decentralized autonomous organization
that is lending to someone who's
actually outside the chain who actually
has a credit a good credit but then what
happens when they don't pay back are you
going to go to the judicial system to
force the execution of a contract that
was half on chain uh how are you going
to actually get all that money back
um so there are a lot of you know there
is a lot of innovation there and
we don't want to go against Innovation
but this is like highly risky it sounds
opposite to the philosophy of D5 it has
level of centralization that we think
are real flags and most likely we think
we are going to have a lot of pain there
and so we're tracking that we're saying
that this is going to be painful uh but
we don't want to close on Innovation
either yeah it's um it's fascinating to
think about uh you all have these risks
identified you're able to grade them and
still lots of people are using these
products and almost don't care to some
degree like like is there an element of
like no the most risky thing is where
the most return potentially is so like I
want to go invest in all the F's like
that would be insane to me but maybe I'm
just uh I'm too risk-averse I don't know
so
um you guys are laughing so like it
seems like maybe yeah like it's a debate
we're having all the time internally
that's what I'm laughing but so um
the worst thing that can happen is you
invest in an f and you don't know it
that's what we're trying to avoid and so
so first step is you know what you're
getting into
and as long as that's happening there is
transparency uh and the user know what's
up now when we allow investing where do
we draw the line for exponential RFI our
platform and so uh we we're still
debating but we think we'll draw the
line probably at C you can invest in ABC
and stay away from dnfs because if you
want to do it at your own risk with
metamask and so on and so forth uh that
that decision has not been finalized but
that's what we're throwing around
internally so number one priority let
the user know what's up number two
Priority One Year building an investment
platform then then build it in a way
that that like helps uh people help
themselves and and invest in in things
that are reasonable effectively yeah uh
oh yeah got it the um
as you look forward
what are you most excited about that you
all are building is it the continuation
and like getting better and more
accurate and under writing the risks or
is it something else the risk is a means
to an end I was like uh okay we want to
allow people to access yield we can't do
it if they can make the right decision
so we have to build that if there was a
third party that did it well we would
have used them they wasn't we built it
uh so ultimately
we want
um
to be the Gateway into D5 we want people
to Access Financial Freedom through
yield because compounding is super
powerful we all know that and so if you
can take uh choose your investment
strategy whatever it is like I want a
third cash a third Bitcoin a third
ethereum for example that's your
strategy instead of letting it sit and
do nothing you take uh you take that put
it on defy and get healed on your core
assets effectively that's what we're
about we're about creating the access
gateway to yield in a way that's simple
compliant secure uh uh where where
things are completely back to back like
we don't mess with customers funds uh
things are if you invest in a pool
um you your your funds are effectively
secured in that pool and that's it there
is no leverage or or so on and so forth
we invest heavily in security uh like
like basically a lot of our things are
multi-sig like for example
uh to change or risk rating it's
multi-stage single person cannot do it
so we need to like we we have a review
process where multiple people need to
debate and agree to to that uh so that
it it so that no single person can go
and say oh this is an a now and let's
draw it so so there's a lot of like core
principles that we're putting into this
so that people access this incredible
ecosystem the right way that that's what
we're about yeah yeah it's um it's
interesting to think about if somebody
else had built the risk identification
you all would have just used them but
instead you felt like you had to build
it uh and does that mean that most
people have just not understood the
risks like like is that kind of the
general takeaway there
today most people invest in default oh
my buddy told me that's a good protocol
I'm going to invest there seems safe no
it's an F here's why so uh no that that
we're trying to bring rationality into
defy that that's uh and and not have
people act because uh it's Buzzy because
it's cool uh but because it's the right
thing for them and it makes sense so
that that's why we built it effectively
to to to to try to uh it's almost boring
to a point because it's it's
mathematical but that's what we're about
it's like and we try to do it we debated
a million ways to like figure out how to
best communicate that and we find great
is easy with a color coding and then uh
Greg make with a transparency where you
go and like can look into everything
that's going into it but yeah that makes
sense at the end of the the day all we
do is like bring a user-centered
approach to defy investing yeah and so
we start we like looking at D5 is an
amazing opportunity and yield in D5 is
the killer app so we want to give access
there is an issue of accessibility that
we want to fix so in order to do that we
had to first start to look at
all the processes the in the decision
making process that you are going to
take as an investor before you click
invest in a pool
so it means that first you need to be
able to discover the pools see and there
was like no Central marketplace where
you can see all the investment
opportunities that are available and
then once you have the
like the holistic view you have to
understand a lot about what are the jobs
being done what does it mean that this
protocol is there is it reliable and
things like that so we went into uh an
educational part which is related to the
risk as well like before investing you
should think about risk and so we
brought all of these together be in
order to build what is the end product
for us which is a one-click invest into
D5 pools once we do that
we are going to be able to basically
have level the playing field for
investors to have access to these
amazing new job opportunity jobs that
are built in D5 from like lending and
borrowing Market making staking which is
like basically validating mining uh
transactions on chain
and all these other jobs that are coming
on stream on chain and and so once we do
that we are going to be able to uh look
into the other things that D5 proposed
like for example options
or um like being able to actually not
invest but borrow all of these things we
can make even easier uh through
exponential fi yeah it makes a lot of
sense where can we send people to find
out more about the business
about the risks uh well they're just the
business in general that you all are
building and then obviously also get
their assets and separated uh
exponential.fi exponential.fi and that's
where they can find the rate my wallet
as well right my wallets available
um you we also have like uh we have a
lot of information educational data you
have like a best risk reward pools uh
you can follow pools and get alerts when
the yield or the risk changes uh for
example you can compare pools across
like chains uh by TDL by rating by a
bunch of things so there's a lot of
tools that we've built to help people
make make the right the the right
decision we also send a weekly Roundup
uh email which is useful for people who
want to follow what's going on what are
things that are trending where things
where risk is changing and so on and so
forth so awesome and then where can they
find you all on the internet on Twitter
on Twitter all right what are your
Twitter handles at exponential D5 and
myself is
an address better more so it's my my
full name but uh I would fall out
exponential D5
all right well listen I appreciate you
guys coming on I think uh this is a
little bit of a wake-up call right to
some people it's like hey look
um I don't understand what the risks are
let me go and use some of these products
to better understand what that risk uh
could be and maybe you're using things
that have no risk uh or very little risk
and then you may be using things that
have incredible amount of risk and if
you don't understand using something
like this to uh to identify that I think
is uh is obviously very important um so
I hope people go check that out and then
we'll definitely do this again in the
future as you guys continue to build out
the product awesome sounds great thank
you for having us and uh yeah to
to better decision making we're super
excited about D5 won't do is make that
accessible and make sure people get that
awesome yield so yeah
awesome guys all right thank you all
right thanks